henri sterdyniak merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france
le mca a donc autorisé ce mardi des
sanctions européennes contre les états
unis
qu'est ce qui a motivé cette décision
qu'elle est le noeud du problème
le noeud du problème c'est que les deux
pays
subventionne d'ailleurs les avionneurs
donc l'europe subventionne airbus les
états unis subventionne bruit et que
chacun tire deux avionneurs fait
pression auprès du gouvernement pour que
son gouvernement portent place à l'om
c'est contre le partenaire et donc on a
une sorte de jeu asean du sang et donc
les états unis ont gagné
il y a 6 mois et ce coup-ci c'est à
l'europe de gagner c'est un jeu bizarre
effectivement vous lisez les états unis
avaient déjà été autorisées à taxer des
produits en provenance du vieux
continent pour un montent à montans
pardon de 7 milliards et demi de dollars
pour la même raison cette fois avec une
aide un dieu des pays européens à airbus
pourquoi le montant des taxes des
américains est supérieur à celui des
européens qui est de 4 milliards inscrit
le principe de l'om sait c'est que les
autorisations sont dépendantes des z
effectivement accordé et de l' avantage
que ça fournit à airbus c'est donc le le
web y ait tant qu le le lot omc a estimé
que les avantages dont vous avez avait
bénéficié
ils sont un peu inférieures à celles
dont airbus avait bénéficié et c'est ce
qui explique cette différence de
montants alors l'union européenne
appelle à la négociation
est ce que cela veut dire que si les
états unis retirent leurs droits de
douane les européens ne taxerons pas les
importations oui bien sûr c'est
effectivement la solution la plus sage à
les deux pays doivent reconnaître que en
fait
l'aviation a besoin d'être aidé surtout
dans la période actuelle est donc des
shows dreer que les deux pays renonce à
cette taxation
surtout que ces surtaxes fera des
produits qui a priori n'ont rien à voir
avec l'aviation et que les surtaxes sa
nuit aussi aux consommateurs de chacun
des pays ayant le l'amérique taxe les
fromages europe et à ce qui nuit d'une
certaine façon au consommateur américain
et l'europe va taxer lekic ap où les les
patates douces importé des états unis ce
qui va nuire aux consommateurs européens
est ce que les états unis seraient
d'accord pour cet accord demandée par
bruxelles
est-ce qu'il l'entende de cette oreille
disons tout va tout va se négocier en
principe avec une personne raisonnable
on voit qu'un accord serait possible
peut-être qu'il va falloir attendre le
départ de donald trump a le problème de
donald trump c'est qu'il a une grande
liste de griefs contre l'europe
il ya un seulement airbus il ya aussi le
fait que l'allemagne apporte trop de
véhicules automobiles au aux états unis
à le fait que les pays européens veulent
taxer les caf a donc de donald trump est
engagée dans une guerre commerciale en
grande partie contre la chine mais aussi
contre l'union européenne et donc la
négociation va être difficile tant qu
effectivement donald trump sera au
pouvoir à washington ont dit attendre de
l'union européenne une réponse à une
récente très proposition de quel type de
proposition peut il s'agir là les
propositions de tram ces deux d'accepter
une limitation volontaire des
importations de exportations de l'union
européenne j'ai
le les états unis et c'est aussi de
renoncer à taxer les gaffes annoncé une
négociation globale trompe
la tactique de crom c'est de faire
pression sur chacun de ses partenaires
commercial en mettant quelque sorte que
le pistolet sous la tempe en menaçant à
chaque fois deux affaires des tensions
des des sanctions le problème de
l'europe cee chacun des pays peut avoir
des intérêts différents
lalanne est très préoccupé par le fait
que les états unis veulent limiter les
importations allemandes les exportations
allemandes vers les états unis
alors que ça concerne moins les autres
pays européens alors le ministre
français de l'économie l'affirmé si les
états unis ne retirent pas leurs propres
taxes nous devons rééquilibrer le
rapport
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
guerre commerciale qui dure on le
rappelle a commencé il ya 16 ans mais
jusqu'à présent on annonce t on à lui
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de trump on
a une montée des tensions entre rome
bâle augmenter massivement les taxes sur
les un peu les exportations chinoises
il veut pratique il a pratiqué des
politiques de menaces extrait de rôle
violentes contre le canada contrôler le
net sig et contre l'europe
hiller il veut faire pareil sachant
qu'il est et s'estime en position de
force puisque les etats-unis importent
beaucoup plus de l'europe que l'europe
importe des deux états unis et donc il
est très différent très difficile
d'aboutir à un cessez le feu à une
baisse de l'ensemble des détaxes parce
que trump considère que le couple est
coupable c'est l'europe puisque l'europe
lui export de trop de marchandises
tandis que l'europe
guère que le coupable c'est les états
unis qui ne respectent pas les règles du
jeu de l'om
merci beaucoup henri sterdyniak pour
votre éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
économiste à l'ouest et de
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques